ready for a challenge here is another
example it's a real case to though I am
adapting that the details for when this
occurred in the 1800s just to get the
the money up to today's standards we
have a rich uncle who is very fond of
his nephew but his nephew he thinks a
young man his late adolescent he kind of
runs in bad company and he needs to get
his act together so what he says look
I'll give you a quarter of a million
dollars when you reach the age of 21 on
condition that in the next few years
before you are 21 you don't drink you
don't smoke you don't swear and you
don't gamble
well the nephew keeps to these terms all
that time he doesn't smoke drink gamble
and come 21 he wants his money now mayor
say in the meanwhile the good-hearted
uncle had died and who the nephew was
suing for the money are his lawyers and
his heirs and though the uncle may have
been minded to give the money the
lawyers are more hard-hearted and they
say we're not going to give you this
money why because it was simply a
promise to make a gift and our Lord does
not enforce promises to make gifts so if
you want to make the gift make your gift
once you make your gift or you hand over
the quarter of a million dollars or your
hand over the silver watch or your hand
over the house well that's fine you've
transferred it now it belongs to the
other person but a promise to make a
gift we're not going to bother with you
can't take that to court well do you
know what happened in this case do you
know one